hey what's this uh you roasted some
opener on the road didn't know your name
your time on your podcast I was laughing
what did I do
so you weren't oh oh oh you heard that
dude have you kiss me no so were you
what is it you're on the road and then
I'm open I didn't know your name well
okay so you know I'm in North Battleford
which is like it's like an hour and a
half away from Saskatoon which is which
is which is up there Canada yeah it's up
there you're hurt nah you need to do
these no they pay me they went to a
guide they were like you wanna go to
casino so was a car lot half cars it's
an so anyway um so so so the guy shows
up and he was like hey man and I was
like ah hey he's goes he says what's
your name
and I was like Chris the guy's opening
for me he's a comedian
and the casino booked them that's the
casinos a lot of times booked their own
yeah yeah yeah I said ah my name is
Chris D'Elia and he says how cool and I
was like oh cool
and I was like whatever he didn't know
my name or maybe you know I pronounced
it fine not a big deal not everybody
needs to know who I am
I'd like to think if you're a comedian
you you would just you know open him for
Christmas Li if you're gonna open how
big is this place it wasn't big it was a
casino in the middle of nowhere
you're right okay so so so I was like so
I was like ah cool and he said so the
next question he said is he said what
what's your how how about what he said
so what what music do you listen to and
I said I literally said what what music
do I listen to and he said yeah and I
and then he said like what do you what
do you what do you what do you do and I
said why don't I just kind of chill out
and hang out and depends you know and I
do but I listen to hip-hop and and and
he said oh so what what's your what's
your show like and I said I mean I just
get up there and kind of tell jokes and
he said oh you're a comedian
and I said yeah uh right yeah and he
said oh oh then I'm gonna stay and watch
you uh I thought you were I thought you
were a musician it makes sense so if the
way you look at me short or or or you do
magic and you are all set to be fair you
always walk around with a guitar I do I
always walk around with a guitar and I
do it like I have a heavy eye makeup
well you like what no I am but I was
like so interest but I was like and and
and I was told to come and do him yes
but he was like my older
yeah he was like 47 I mean older than me
but he was like younger than but he was
like but he was like do you do you he's
like I just got the gig I didn't really
ask I just said yes and I was like oh
it's all good and I was like when the
day he's like I just got the gig I
didn't look you up or anything I was
like ah cool and he was like I was like
what did you get the gig and he was like
two days ago he got time to Google me
did you say sir do you live under a rock
I mean whatever I'm not that big I
understand but like he's a comedian he's
gonna open for me yeah that's kind of
homework yeah just how was this comedy I
actually didn't really listen I I have a
feeling though every time I checked in
it was very like Canada and local ship
yeah you know but uh you know yeah there
are I'm listening to comics sometimes
can be like you get to a point you can
hear about 30 seconds yeah and you
understand yeah you get it you get it
it's really it's interesting like you
can you can tell just by their
confidence and their setup and just
[ __ ] hey what's up the music I mean
like you can try yeah you know what I
have fun do it and I'll see you guys
bring a comic you have your own open
yeah usually otherwise I want to shoot
like dude I was in Canada before you
even said I was in Canada for a week I
didn't have an opener with me because I
had to shoot the good doctor and then
run around and do some gigs it was just
too expensive to fly amount of [ __ ] and
I was just like in the middle of I was
like alone yeah yeah that's usually why
bring my brother with me but you know
yeah I bring my brother and me almost
everybody does all the heat yeah and
then I do if like I'm in La Jolla or if
it's somewhere close I'll bring that hey
soo straight off oh he's [ __ ]
I love that yeah but yeah it's great
I've been having fun because when I go
all around has a road dog but I go yeah
Dublin London
listen B so what I go to all these
freaking nights you know every city I'll
have their local comic with me yeah and
then some are monsters and then some of
them not someone's yeah yeah and you can
see why some are brutal yeah somewhere
brutal and I'm like man I'll tell the
manager Mike you guys and it's a good
club Mike you guys have him open for
everyone yeah I'm like dang that's crazy
because huh
do you know some I'm like holy [ __ ] how
are you not yeah there's this the guys
works like hey move dude and then you go
back a year later or two years later the
same guy you're like and and they always
say yeah I'm gonna get that LA this
summer and they don't come and they take
my number yeah sure just gonna you're
just gonna you're not gonna make it dude
and that's fine if you don't want to but
they do you know what happened to me I
know though I like not knowing that
there's that variable where even listen
if if they bomb it does suck for the
overall show but I know I'm gonna do my
thing yeah but it's fun having that
variable cuz I'll listen the guy brought
up me up in North Battleford he brought
me up tell me your name he was like he
said but I mean openers got my name
wrong oh you would you'd be shocked you
think it's like Chris D'Elia something
like in Canada not this past time last
time Chris Delhi and dude and he was
bombing in a theater but how do you
follow me to theater with my crowd
they're [ __ ] so jacked yeah and this
guy says Chris Delhi why do you love
this out I got a girl in st. Louis she's
like alright everyone it's your
headliners
you've been waiting for it it's Brandon
Skye and I got the mic and go are you
[ __ ] yeah you got it's fun yeah
Branden Schwab makes me I go crazy hate
that I hate it I had a guy the only time
I ever had a like a real issue as I came
in he was my feature and he he was on
his phone he looked up and he goes
something like so like that and I was
like all right that's all good yeah and
then he got up and started doing stuff
like this is a full house and he started
reading oh geez on his nobody's trying
jokes out yeah and then and then people
go tell be funny or something like that
somebody said that and he then he turned
on the crowd you gotta go out and so I
came back and I go like this I go um how
long does this be this is probably six
seven years ago and I came back and you
know me you can't get me mad I know
you're the nicest kind of crowd yeah and
I came out and I said I go dude dude I
went dude here you're reading from your
name yeah yeah and you're turning them
against you when I get up there you
maybe maybe maybe arises on the bright
time cuz it's a gonna be a packed
weekend it was a place where I do well I
go it's gonna be packed weekend so maybe
don't do that joking around you know I'm
laughter yeah and I get it you're trying
to say please don't do that yes right I
do it I'm not appropriate do your good
stuff so that you can set me up and yeah
yeah also do your good stuff cuz this
people here to see Bryan maybe they're
gonna like exactly what he goes like
this he goes BB he goes he goes now
you'll be fine now you'll be fine oh
yeah and I went I went he goes now now
you're not I you'll be fine dude they'll
like they'll like you'll be fine and I'd
like that dismiss me and I and I just
went I go but I won't be fine I'm just
telling you man
and I just smiled like that yeah you did
it again the next night and that's so
mean I said to that and what's he doing
what's he doing now get a different guy
I'm the club owners Applebee's the club
owner said to me she goes he's he's
always been that guy who could have been
something how about I'm not you see what
city I was in or who it was yeah I get
in the room and I'm sitting I can tell
the vibes a little weird like they're
not really talking mean I'm listed and
I'm the punter on the football team I'm
the weird ball out when I'm around a
comic so I come in I'm overly nice I'm
talking about when can I can feel
there's like this weird vibe yeah and
they're sitting I go what's up fellas
and nothing disco so I'm like to me fun
one a nightmare
think you know two sold-out shows the
Wednesday night excite for this man and
then the manager comes in she's like you
know good to see you know great
everything's sold out like the crowds
it's crazy man you got good fans like
that crazy and then homeboy goes must be
nice to have your own audience and
sellout shows and you've been doing it
for how I don't know a month and he said
that yeah it's that true would you say I
and I went I want excuse me and he goes
I'm just saying man you know it's a
grind for a lot of saud hey loser why
not your pride just I went yeah man the
whole goal is to build an audience right
and sell tickets I said it's crazy man
I've done over 100 shows man so things
are going good he goes it must be nice
I'll say that must be nice so much Jesus
cry don't take me I see out there
brother like I just want another Dom you
ready do a show man I can't wait til
after this podcast you tell me who that
is yeah I wanted to go before the show
right dude you wonder why you're not
yeah I know I know that why would you
dude they gave me a I picked you out
like I'm trying to I know I know I don't
like I don't like a lot of like sayings
and stuff but I had an acting teacher
who was an older guy and had a very
influential guy but he said he's always
say attitude monitors your talent and it
monitors your life and he said he was 70
or something he goes yeah you guys I've
seen so many people who could have done
so many things in their attitude their
negative attitude just stopped them and
that's a classic example you see it all
the time you especially see it with
comedian yes you know because they
you're literally your attitude is your
act you know right and then you bring it
off stage and then you see these guys
and you're like and they're just like
[ __ ] this guy [ __ ] that guy and it's
like yeah that's a pole you don't want
me around and I'll so you know we joke
around like all the time like they
gained some cash and I get to the
waitress and this opener who's tell me
how hard it like how hard times are on
them right now so he gave me like a wad
of cash and now you're here I'm [ __ ]
rich I don't need it joking yeah going
[ __ ] right yeah like in the yeah I'm
signed in because you talk were for
everybody yeah yeah but I was gonna give
to no matter what I'm making a joke so
it doesn't feel like ours and you're
generous you do that yeah all the time I
never take that when we cash I make I
give it to the staff so I give that in
the guy goes unbelievable
I thought I was serious I'm like dude
what is your I got I gotta find out who
will I know this guy
I don't think so so wait what do you
mean I think hash you get what it would
mean like from the Comedy Store
oh gosh from merch or if they give me
cash from VIPs whereas usually I give it
to all the employees about you've got
checks right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]